hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his book the stoic paradox is one of
the difficult points for many people to
accept that Cicero brings up one of the
key ideas of the Stoics is that virtue
or moral goodness is sufficient for
happiness as a matter of fact you might
say he even goes beyond that saying that
unless you have virtue you will not be
happy if you are valuing other things
you will actually wind up being unhappy
sooner or later and whatever happiness
you do enjoy will not be genuine
happiness and what this comes down to in
his discussion is really a contrast
between what we can call self
sufficiency and being dependent upon
what the ancients and the medieval is
called fortune and we we might call it
being subject to contingency or events
or things that are essentially outside
of our control so why is it that there
is this this important contrast and how
does it play up this rule tells us that
virtue will in fact make us
self-sufficient why will it do that
that's a key element of this why will
being practically wise or just or
courageous or a temperate why will those
make a self-sufficient well what does it
mean to be self-sufficient it means to
not depend upon other people or things
external factors but to be able to
determine how things are for you in the
ways that matter most by yourself
through your own actions now you could
be self-sufficient in a way and also
screw up your life I suppose but the
person who is truly self-sufficient is
not going to be doing that so happiness
really cannot be taken away from them
the happiness that they do enjoy and
they will indeed be happy in Cicero's
view he's going to talk about this as
being praiseworthy what
we'll talk about in just a moment so one
thing I would like to highlight here is
mrs. in paradox - he says addressing his
audience that you don't know how great
is the strength that virtue possesses
you utter the name virtue but you don't
know what virtue itself means and if you
did fully understand what virtue is
which will entail in some some respects
not only you know sort of a cognitive
thing but a practical thing having
developed the virtues within one at
least to a certain extent or being
properly oriented along the lines of the
virtues then it's possible to understand
just how strong the virtues are how they
are able to make a person happy in in
their life he also says no one can fail
to be supremely happy who relies solely
on himself and who places all his
possessions within himself alone and so
pursuing virtue as the primary good or
the good from which other goods flow the
good that others should be sacrificed to
if need be is going to make that person
self-sufficient by placing everything
that could go wrong or could go right
within their own purview now by contrast
he talks about fortune those who place
their hopes their desires in fortune in
things outside of their control in
random events in the workings of the
world in the proverbial wheel of fortune
that raises some up and lowers others at
the same time that's actually setting
yourself up for having some some real
problems he says those who hang their
hopes entirely on fortune can have
nothing certain there's no there's no
certainty - that nothing that they can
be assured will remain with them for a
single day they may enjoy all sorts of
things in a present moment but they
can't be assured that that is going to
continue on so we see people who for
example strike it rich
and lose the money or they win the
relationship that they've been seeking
but then things don't pan out over time
and they lose that love and affection
and esteem that they had from the other
person there's all sorts of things that
can be taken away from us interestingly
in this case Cicero is going to bring up
because he's talking as if he's he's
addressing his political enemies death
and exile and by by extension loss of
possessions
now the ordinary person who is placing
his or her hopes in the realm of fortune
is going to be very threatened by death
and probably you can use it to coerce
them into doing whatever it is that you
you wish them to do so Cicero is going
to tell us how that's not an issue for
him likewise exile having to go away
from where you are accustomed to live
the place that you are familiar with and
that that whole network of relationships
that you have built up over time when we
might think about this in our own time
not only in terms of physical space or a
particular country but even in terms of
virtual space if you get kicked off of
Twitter right that's a kind of Exile
it's a sanction that people are imposing
on you loss of possessions anything that
we have that is a possession can be
taken away this chalkboard could be
taken away could be destroyed could fall
apart you know these these lights this
book this time any of these things can
go away at any moment and we can try as
much as we wish to safeguard them you
know we can hire a personal security
firm or have an alarm or you know put
our clothes in mothballs or whatever we
like you know put our bind our books and
fancy bindings you know and make sure
that it's on special paper
none of that guarantees that any of
those things won't be destroyed or be
taken away from us and turn to somebody
else so if we subject ourselves to
fortune we not only subject ourselves to
the physical
world but we also subject ourselves to
the whims and desires of other people
and there are going to be certain
consequences to this Cicero's says
people think that they're going to be
happy they're going to they're going to
be ah to us they're going to be blessed
and they're going to flourish if they
have enough of these sorts of goods of
fortune but that's not really the case
instead what they're likely to end up
feeling
besides you know momentary happiness or
momentary joy which is often excessive
is fear fear of losing these things fear
when they are threatened fear about
things that aren't even threatening them
yet but they need to think about ahead
of time and then sadness or sorrow when
these things are taken away from them or
when they are imposed on them like exile
and they will they'll also feel desire
and lust since he says to pity tasks for
for these these things they are going to
be driven they're going to be subjected
to them if you know that that somebody
really really wants the newest iPhone
you can make them do all sorts of things
matter of fact they're television shows
devoted specifically to getting people
to do all sorts of goofy things you know
motivated by their desires their fears
for goods of fortune
now coming back to this issue of being
praiseworthy this role ends paradox too
by telling us that the good and brave
and wise person now notice that that you
know wise and and brave these are
virtues right cannot be wretched or
miserable nor yet can he whose virtue
and whose character deserve praise fail
to live a life that is praiseworthy this
doesn't mean that anyone will in fact
praise them but they can praise
themselves they can wrest certain that
what they are doing is indeed the right
thing the right way to live the right
choices to make they can have a sort of
self-esteem that is genuine self-esteem
and not just everybody gets a gold
our sort of stuff and he says further a
life that's praiseworthy is not a life
to free from it would be a life to flee
from if it were indeed wretched but
whatever is praiseworthy must be deemed
to be happy and prosperous and desirable
they asked him at Florence at expending
the deity be ottoman Florence a life
that is happy and flourishing genuine
flourishing comes from the virtues and a
life devoted to virtue now I wanted to
also mention Cicero talks about death
and exile here and he says you can
threaten me and he was indeed threatened
with death but that is not going to
really affect me because my you know you
can take my life away from me you can
take my capacity to enjoy my possessions
but you won't change who I am you won't
take away as he says my glory which is
not a glory that's dependent simply on
people saying nice things about you he
also said something very interesting
about exile as well he says so you wish
to exile me exile is really only a
threat to those whose domicile is
encircled by a bounding line not to
those who deem the whole world to be a
single city this is the stoic doctrine
of cosmopolitanism of the entire world
being your political community being
your polis and Cicero is in fact
endorsing this from the stoic
perspective and saying this renders
exile less of a threat so the road to
genuine happiness does not lie in
dependency on fortune but rather in the
self-sufficiency that cultivating the
virtues affords one
you